hey Don I heard Greenland is looking for
a king they want a new monarch with
dictatorial powers and you get like ten
planes I heard I heard you could totally
do that if you gave up being president
and you went there and asked them I hear
they're super interested in you good
joke on him tell him that tell him
there's like a secret compartment in the
presidential limousine that always has
hot Big Macs in it what
tragedy in the Trump world they finally
lost this guy I think you have to
consider a change at the top of the
ticket when someone is acting like this
he has a nihilistic way to his
personality so the minute you say
something he doesn't like he he figures
that he can intimidate you like a bully
there's a pernicious evil in trying to
divide the country so many big words yet
the involuntarily foul-mouthed guy who
the media saw as a non-serious Butthead
is now finally being treated as a
serious Butthead because he turned on
Trump it's the strange new respect rule
the people who can't stand you will
lavish you with attention once you jump
ship and the turncoat he craves it so
now he's on CNN and MSNBC who treat him
like an Oracle held together with hair
gel as he hopes that one day he'll end
up on Real Housewives of Coney Island
it's so good
he's now among the other Desperate
oddballs boots Ruben Walsh they roam the
countryside more affected by Trump than
the Trump supporters they demean because
this is less about the acceptance of
Trump than it is a rejection of them
mooch is best known for being close to
power for 13 seconds mayflies lasted
longer in the White House and that's the
motivating factor after all Trump's
never changed but the mooch the lime
lights fading and that taste of stardom
was so delicious but Trump's moved on he
now wants to buy Greenland's
that is awesome and it's no surprise
he's a real-estate guy he probably wants
to buy it so he can flip it add some
granite countertops and a sub-zero
fridge some nice bathroom amenity is
done it leads me to wonder do you love
cranes or trucks
I love cranes I love trucks of all types
even when I was a little boy at four
years old my mother would say you love
trucks I do I always love trucks I still
do nothing changes sometimes you know
you might become president but nothing
changes I still love trucks nothing
changes but what about the rain I said
don't worry about the rain do we have
umbrellas don't worry about the rain and
brothers worked very well it's so true
he speaks the truth about the umbrella
and what do we send them wheat we send
them wheat wheat that's not a good deal
and they don't even want our wheat they
do it because they want us to at least
feel that we're okay you know they do it
to make us feel good and all of a sudden
it stops the wind all of a sudden it
stops the wind and the televisions go
off and your wives and husbands say
darling I want to watch Donald Trump on
television tonight that but the winds
stopped blowing and I can't watch
there's no electricity in the house
darling remember when the city used to
build little pieces the city used to
build little pieces of the epc little
piece there little piece here little
piece there a few years later a little
piece here and what about your campaign
manager I earrings really tall is now
our campaign manager and he's one of the
tallest human beings I've ever seen
when you don't have to look for anybody
you just look over and you see a guy
who's twice as tall as everyone but
whether you love him or hate him you
gotta vote for him whether you love me
or hate me they got a vote for me
so what is the Democrat strategy to be
boring Thursdays Washington Post claims
what people want is the opposite of
Trump someone not so exhausting who
doesn't force you to think constantly
about politics now I get it promising
serenity is persuasive going from Trump
to say Biden it's like putting on that
comfy sweater after a weekend of wearing
nothing but leather chaps I know that
feeling
but it's BS remember these are the same
people who made politics personal and
failed at it
so now they're tired of politics
interfering with their gloomy personal
lives screw you now you know how we've
felt since the 1960s
there let's been injecting politics into
everything sports movies bedrooms
everywhere we go we're being lectured
about how we're complicit in evil use a
straw you hate sea turtles play catch
with your kid you reinforce gender
stereotypes worked out it equinox
you're obviously Satan so this trump is
so exhausting is just BS based on the
fact that the BS errs finally now have
real opposition it's like when they talk
of polarization that's code for remember
the good old days when there was just
one side yep polarization requires an
adversary and before Trump Republicans
didn't have one that could beat the
ugliness coming from that other side
before Trump lives could crap on you day
and night now the Republicans got a crap
cannon and it ain't never gonna stop
shooting crap Adam
of course now they pretend to what
normalcy as they intensify their own
campaign of demonization they keep
widening the target it's not Trump who's
the problem it's also the people around
him and his family and that people have
voted for him and people who didn't vote
for him but support him and people who
watch him on TV and people who don't
foam at the mouth when he's mentioned
and the people who aren't actively
resisting him it's a combination trade
and race war the left now punishes half
the population by targeting smearing
daxing any businesses that might employ
anyone who would support Trump one
wonder is how far this could go but
Jeana macadamia nuts we want some no
okay macadamia nuts are grown in Hawaii
you know what else is in Hawaii a Trump
International Hotel Hawaii directly
benefits from that hotel so no I will
not be having any of your macadamia nuts
[Music]
is that a flier shirt yeah favorite team
Wow what is Wow
what Flyers in Philadelphia it's in
Pennsylvania a state Trump won in 2016
nice endorsement of white supremacy okay
well it's that huh this you mean my
Captain America action figure oh you
mean Marvel's captain America action
figure the same Marvel whose CEO Isaac
Perlmutter gave money to Donald Trump
this year what's that a bandana nice
bandana man just like the one worn by
Bret Michaels in Celebrity Apprentice
hosted by Donald Trump
well what about your shoes huh aren't
those the same shoes that were on 49th
Street between 5th and 6th Avenue where
Saturday Night Live is filmed the same
SNL that gave Donald Trump a platform
and letting him host the show twice what
about your five year olds drawings look
at them they obviously use Crayola
Crayons Crayola Crayons
owned by hallmark which owns hallmark
channel which aired a film called
broadcasting Christmas starring known
Trump supporter Dean Cain how dare you
is that a kilt you know Trump's mother
is Scottish fine
Steve are we not - until Thursday yeah
thanks Trump tonight's guest he's so
sharp children are not allowed to run
with him author political commentator
notes of the March Stein show March
Stein
even his epitaph will make you laugh
comedian Joe Mackey she's funny and
smart and a little bit tart host of
sincerely count on Fox Nation tactic if
you follow in his footsteps you may need
a ladder to get out my massive sidekick
host of nuff said on Fox Nation Tyrus
we covered a lot here mark what feel
free to comment on anything
what up the scaramouche II Greenland the
new trade war against Americans by
Americans anything I gotta go back to
that pre credits thing right I've never
seen Rachel Maddow telling a joke before
she's got that whole Hillary bobblehead
you know when Hillary tells a joke
Rachel Maddow's got the whole Hillary
and even on the side because what was
she saying she said soul Trump wants to
buy Greenland so he could be
professional that's why they're so
exhausted by Trump right and they've got
the discipline to be boring when they
say make America boring again as you say
for decades they've insisted their guys
are fascinating like Clinton Obama even
Al Gore they put them on the cover of
Vanity Fair fog rolling stone they
pretend they're celebrities right even
bait oh they put on the cover of vanity
bait oh who thinks instagramming himself
having ear hair removed yes is
interesting and that's the point about
politics I think is they did boring
things that the media represented to us
as glamorous so like bait OA walks ear
hair is glam yes in a way that Bob
Dole's ear hair isn't yes he's actually
got a lot more of it yes so so I I think
they don't have that it takes guts and
courage to have the conviction of your
own boring and they don't have the
integrity to be as as completely boring
as they should be
yes I'm gonna try it for the rest of the
show it's going quite well so you
start yeah alright Joe what are you
excited about Greenland are you excited
about anything I'll tell you what it's
been a rollercoaster for Greenland
because if you read what Trump actually
said there was in a meeting and someone
said Denmark is having a lot of trouble
with how much they have to spend on
Greenland and someone said you should
buy it
and he said is that even possible what
do you think it no point said he was
gonna buy penguin but people in
Greenland were offended at the idea that
America wanted to buy them you should be
so lucky I don't understand why there's
such a consensus among Democrats that
apparently what they need to beat Donald
Trump is a boring candidate if that were
the case Hillary Clinton would have won
yes in 2016 yeah I mean she's boring and
it's actually impressive that she
manages to be so boring because usually
people who have been the subject of
involved criminal investigations are at
least a little bit exciting yes she's
like the most boring criminal ever you
know like I have eaten rice cakes with
more pizzazz you know so I just think
that maybe they should think about that
yeah you know but they don't know they
don't what about you tires last word I'm
just I'm so oh man laughs this hard
since I was a little schoolgirl man in
my lifetime growing up I've lit I've
witnessed and read a lot of history
about racism and stuff but this white
racist stuff is awesome we're gonna buy
white people this is amazing we're gonna
show a little why in the truck let's go
we've been bought like this no I'm Wow
we've come yeah I gotta back up this is
amazing we're about to buy some white
people awesome
do
you always put a unique spin on this
yeah this is awesome all white men nope
and buying that's all Greenland
Greenland I look forward to our 51st
state I always thought those people were
green stop there